ALL AROUNDTHE LAST
FIVE AGAINST CAROLINA.
LOOKING FOR NIEMI  A THREE ON T
THE METRO.
WASHINGTON WASAME.
>> Craig: WHEN CAROLINA IS WA
THERE'S TROCHECK.
JUST LIKE THAT IT'S FEREE EXPLAG
TO TJ.
TH AGO CAROLINA PK UNIT.
HOVERRERING AROUND 20% ALL
SEAS THE END
OF THESCE HAS IT FOR CAROLINA.
WITH ROOM,
FOR T GOING ONE ON ONE.
HE GETS INSIDE POSITION.
THE ICE
LIKE EVERY O O MARK OF
REGULATIONPLAY.
STARTS WITH THE HAWK OFF.
THEY TAKE IT TO ASTIC PLAY THE S
MOVING THINKING THAT MINIMUM ST
ROLE FOR YOURS PERIOD THEY
DIDN'T MUSTER
THE CAPITALS A COUPLE E
TO THE JERSEY.
AND IN THE
THIRD.
HE HAS TWO GOALS TONIGHT.
SHANE LETS6-1. THEY RUN
HAPPENED THEY'VE BEEN A
SHORTHANDED.
THE REST HAVE ALL  ALVI.
>> Craig: A